you hear that bump better didn't
boom-boom and I'm like well just a
little work pass patiently waiting every
expectation reactions so like I was like
auditioning for this like show in high
school that I thought was a talent show
I was gonna like sing a love song
mom's gonna love it and then that'll be
that but then ended up being a musical
and they like gave me the lead in the
musical and I was like nah I'm not doing
that that's too many lines to learn no
way I eventually decided to do it and I
had a great time doing it and I I just
was like maybe I can't keep doing this
got my nickname when I was in middle
school
everybody always messed up my name so it
gave me MC oak tree that's how it
started and I hated it at first but then
when I got to college and everyone's
like drunk and like aliens your name and
I'd say my name and then I were like
well people in high school called me oak
tree like what that's crazy cause like
you know everything's awesome when
you're wasted in your 18 oh look at
that for real my friends came from
college she came the other day she was
like that's just the best one is just
Anthony that's just us him that's
exactly like that's what he does and
that made me feel good you know that
made me feel like all right I had faith
that this will kind of work itself out
so I had all sorts of jobs and my main
focus was just like pay your rent and if
you get like a gig that's like a bonus I
just tried to have faith that things
will come and they come if I just keep
like working hard it sounds super cheesy
you know but like be ready when the
opportunity arrives the music is like
nothing I was like particularly excited
about you know getting in the room with
with Lynn and Tommy and and getting
actually like rap you know and and
getting the sing
remember this we handed it to me because
I had to dance had to sing I had to wrap
I had to I mean you know I had like four
auditions for this but um you know it
kept getting better every step of the
way so I was like a lot of fun it
differs from other musicals in the music
the subject matter and in the casting
and it's just me it's contemporary man
this is like everything there's no jazz
hands there's you know there's none of
that man this like this is the gritty
hip-hop R&B I mean there's so many
different genres of music in one sitting
this is the the biggest melting pot of
stuff in one sitting I've ever been
if you don't fit it's because you're not
supposed to fit and they'll come at I'm
going to do fit everybody the show is
very very specific someone show
the people who are there as the people
but like you think about it like hip-hop
musical ham like what it doesn't really
make sense but it only makes sense when
you see it but again it's like it's the
Wild West sometimes in Broadway it's
like who knows you think something's
great and people are like now we kind of
hate it and it closes in like six months
so I was just hoping that when it was
released that people loved it as much as
like we all loved the thing and then it
started happening and it was like this
was great I just kept building and
building getting bigger and bigger and
bigger now to the point where I'm like
get out of my way Tyra Banks oh I want
to meet that Rick Rubin you know it's
like it's just it's like nuts it's like
you're pushing people out of the way to
meet other people it's kind of ugly
it's the best learning experience I've
ever had in my own life but at the end
of the day what's most important